Es ist paradox, dass wenn noch immer keine spuren von außerirdischen gefunden haben, und es gibt sogar einen namen für dieses paradoxon
Dass fermi paradoxon, es beschreibt die eigentlich wirklich sehr seltsame situation
Alien sollten doch schon seit sehr langer zeit existieren und zeit gehabt haben das weltall zu erobern doch nirgendwo findet sich eine spur
Der beweis dafür, dass es gar keine außerirdischen gibt, also gibt es nun welche oder keine
Das klären wir jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen und am ende des videos habe ich noch ein kleines goodie für euch
so, also, ich gebe mich geschlagen, ihr habt das thema jetzt hunderte male vorgeschlagen, also hier ist es wenn es denn
Außerirdisches leben geben sollte und ihr wisst, die wahrscheinlichkeit ist
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht so klein sollten wir es dann nicht überall um uns herum haben
Denn schließlich müssen intelligente außerirdische doch in der lage sein die gesamte
Galaxie zu kolonisieren und dann müssten wir doch über hinweise zu ihnen nur so stolpern
Dem ist aber nicht so toll da raus, also die schlussfolgerung, dass es keine intelligenten außerirdischen gibt
Dass unsere ganze suche nach ihnen von vornherein
Erfolglos ist und war genau dieses gedankenexperiment soll der physiker enrico fermi im jahr
1950 aufgestellt haben und zwar auf einem weg zum mittagessen
Als er im gespräch mit einigen seiner kollegen über ufo-sichtungen und die existenz von außerirdischen
Überhaupt war am ende so heißt es soll er dann gesagt haben, wer is everybody?
Dass wir trotz intensiver suche keinerlei spuren von außerirdischen leben finden
sei einfach nur paradox und so sei es höchste zeit unsere annahmen dazu oder aber unsere beobachtungen in diesem
Zusammenhang zu hinterfragen doch das fermi paradoxon, sorgt, bis heute zu hitzigen diskussionen
Diskutiert wird sogar, ob enrico fermi diese behauptung überhaupt jemals aufgestellt hat der amerikanische autor robert brain beispielsweise
Der selbst nach signalen von außerirdischen gesucht hat bezweifle das sehr stark, er ist nicht der ansicht
Dass wir jemals ein wort über außerirdische verloren habe, gray ist dagegen der festen überzeugung, dass das ganze auf einem missverständnis
Basiert denn schließlich habe man nur die erinnerung vom vermisst kollegen, der satz, wer is everybody aus vermissen und sei völlig anders zu interpretieren
Als es das fermi paradoxon verbreite ein kollege erinnerte sich demnach noch sehr gut daran, dass fermi selbst mit spekulierte
Warum es bisher an außerirdischen hinweisen fehlt
Der physiker selbst habe überlegt, das interstellare reisen gegebenenfalls einfach noch nicht möglich sein
Oder das den außerirdischen, der ganze aufwand einfach nicht wert sein so ging es bei seiner frage, also eher darum
Warum eine reise von stern so stern nicht möglich ist das wundert jedenfalls nicht denn zu diesem zeitpunkt
Also 1950 hatte noch keine rakete die erdumlaufbahn oder aber einen anderen himmelskörper
Erreicht sputnik war noch nicht im erdorbit
Angelangt fermi soll demnach aber keineswegs grundsätzlich an der existenz von außerirdischen
Leben gezweifelt haben doch
Das hat sich wohl so verfestigt mit fatalen folgen
1981 beschloss der amerikanische politiker william trox meyer das nasa programm namens seti finanziell nicht weiter zu fördern
Sie steht für search for extraterrestrial intelligence
Und die begründung für die beendigung des programms musste damals und so für die begründung tatsächlich das fermi paradoxon
Er halt 975 jedenfalls dachte der astronom michael hart weiter auf dem sogenannten fermi paradoxon herum er
Argumentierte tatsächlich, dass die menschen die einzigen intelligenten lebewesen in der galaxis sein
Denn ansonsten hätte das außerirdische leben dort bereits die gesamte milchstraße erobert doch auch hier gibt es wiederum viele die vehement dagegen halten
Wer sagt denn, dass sie unbedingt neue galaxien kolonisieren wollen oder unsere galaxie
vielleicht waren sie aber auch schon längst bei uns und die beweise dafür sind zusammen mit den dinosauriern von der erde verschwunden und woher
Sollten die außerirdischen überhaupt die ressourcen haben, um unzählige andere sterne zu bereisen. Jedenfalls ist die bezeichnung
Paradoxon irreführend, denn wo ist der widerspruch zwischen den beiden thesen
Wir finden hier keine außerirdischen bei uns und irgendwo wird es außerirdische geben
Schließlich weiß niemand, ob reisen zwischen den sternen überhaupt möglich sind fahrlässig ist es jedenfalls
Die suche nach außerirdischen im kosmos deswegen zu unterlassen, weil wir bei uns bisher keine hinweise darauf gefunden haben
Schließlich haben wir bisher nicht einmal einen bruchteil
Des kosmos unter die lupe genommen und wir berichten hier bei klicks und science fiction ja immer wieder mal darüber
Dass wir selbst hier auf, der erde krasse erkenntnisse in diesem zusammenhang machen beispielsweise, dass mikroben auch bei extremen temperaturen
Überleben können, also eigentlich sprechen alle indizien für die existenz von außerirdischen
Wer weiß, was die nächsten jahre bringen die chancen für unsere suche steigen jedenfalls, wenn beispielsweise das nasa-weltraumteleskop
James, webb planeten auf die chemische zusammensetzung ihrer atmosphäre untersuchen wird ja und jetzt gibt es zehn euro für jeden
Ungelogen meine web community hat mich gebeten einen special deal auszuhandeln und ich habe ihn
Bei dem von stiftung warentest am besten getesteten cashback portal gibt es zehn euro plus noch
Sondern schmeckt, das ganze bekommt, die am morgigen sonntag
Wenn ihr euch hier bei whatsapp anmeldet einfach draufklicken
whatsapp
Erfahrt ihr auch von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich und garantiert und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren
Da gibt es das neueste aus, der social media welt dafür hier klicken, aber nicht die
Glocke vergessen, hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken dem neuesten zu
Indizien und spuren von leben auf dem mars, also, da gibt es ja auch schon weiter, also. Bis dann
lauter